THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS WILL NOW COME TO
ORDER. WE ARE HOLDING OUR
HEARING TODAY IN ROOM 2200 OF
THE Ó STREET BUILDING. I ASK
ALL MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE TO
PLEASE COME TO THE HEARING ROOM
SO THAT WE CAN BEGIN THE
HEARING. AND I HAVE HEARD FROM A
COUPLE OF MEMBERS WHO ARE IN
ANOTHER HEARING RIGHT NOW, SO
HOPEFULLY THEY WILL JOIN US
SOON. WE HAVE NINE MEASURES ON
TODAY'S AGENDA, THREE OF WHICH
WILL BE ELIGIBLE FOR A DUE PASS
MOTION. THE REST OF OUR BILLS
ARE SUSPENSE CANDIDATES. AS
USUAL, WE WILL EXTEND A COURTESY
TO ANYONE THAT HAS A Dð PASS
ITEM BEFORE US AND ALLOW THEM TO
PRESENT THEIR BILL OUT OF AGENDA
ORDER AS THEY SHOW UP. ALL
MEMBERS WITH SUSPENSE ITEMS
BEFORE THE COMMITTEE THIS
MORNING HAVE WAIVED PRESENTATION
MEANS THAT THEY WON'T BE
PRESENTING THEIR BILLS. HOWEVER
WE WILL BE TAKING TESTIMONY FROM
THE PUBLIC ON EACH AND EVERY
ITEM, EVEN IF THE AUTHOR HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION. THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE HAS
INDICATED THAT THEY ARE VERY
BUSY WITH THE BUDGET, AND SO
THEY WILL NOT HAVE ANY COMMENTS
ON ANY OF THE MEASURES BEFORE
THE COMMITTEE, SO THEY WON'T BE
PRESENT TO TESTIFY HERE TODAY.
THERE MAY BE INDIVIDUALS THAT
HAVE NEVER ATTENDED OR
PARTICIPATED IN AN
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE BEFORE.
THIS IS A COMMITTEE THAT REVIEWS
BILLS THAT WILL COST MONEY.
BEFORE WE BEGIN, I WANT TO
REMIND ANY WITNESSES TO LIMIT
THEIR TESTIMONY TO THE FISCAL
ASPECTS OF THE BILL, BECAUSE
THAT'S WHAT THIS COMMITTEE DOES.
PLEASE REFRAIN FROM LENGTHY
POLICY DISCUSSIONS AND REPEATING
PRIOR TESTIMONY IN YOUR
COMMENTS. I MAY ALSO NEED TO
PLACE SOME LIMITS ON WITNESS
TESTIMONY, BUT I WILL ENSURE
THAT EQUAL TIME IS AFFORDED TO
SUPPORTERS AND OPPONENTS. SO SO
BEFORE WE BEGIN OUR HEARING
TODAY ON THE MEASURES BEFORE US,
LET'S ESTABLISH A QUORUM. MADAM
ASSISTANTS, PLEASE. ASSISTANT
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. CABALLERO.
HERE. CABALLERO. HERE JONES. I'M
HERE. JONES. HERE. ASHBY. BECKER
BRADFORD. CIERTO. CIERTO. HERE
WAHAB. WAHAB. HERE WE HAVE A
QUORUM. SO WE'RE GOING TO START
OUR HEARING FOR TODAY. OUR FIRST
ITEM BECAUSE BECAUSE HE IS
PRESENT WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON
TO ITEM NUMBER SIX ON OUR AGENDA
A B 1955 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER WARD
. WELCOME. ASSEMBLY MEMBER. THE
FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK YOU, MADAM
CHAIR AND SENATORS, I'M HERE TO
PRESENT AB 1955 TO SUPPORT
ACADEMIC FUTURES AND EDUCATORS
FOR TODAY'S YOUTH ACT OR SAFETY
ACT, WHICH DOES THE FOLLOWING
THINGS. FIRST, THE BILL
PROHIBITS AND INVALIDATES ANY
POLICY, RULE OR ADMINISTRATIVE
REGULATION THAT REQUIRES A
FORCED OUTING AS DEFINED.
SECOND, THIS BILL CLARIFIES THAT
TEACHERS SHALL NOT BE COMPELLED
TO DISCLOSE SUCH AN IDENTITY
UNLESS REQUIRED TO DO SO UNDER
STATE AND FEDERAL LAW. THIRD,
THE BILL PROTECTS TEACHERS FROM
FACING RETALIATION FOR SIMPLY
DOING THEIR JOBS, TEACHING, AND
PROVIDING A SAFE SCHOOL
ENVIRONMENT. AND FOURTH, THE
SAFETY ACT PROVIDES PARENTS AND
FAMILIES OF LGBTQ STUDENTS WITH
CRITICAL RESOURCES IN ORDER TO
SUPPORT THEM IN WORKING TOWARDS
ACCEPTANCE ON THEIR OWN TERMS,
WITHOUT INTERFERENCE FROM
OUTSIDE ACTORS TO SPEAK TO THE
FISCAL IMPACT OF THE BILL. THE
SAFETY ACT WOULD HAVE MINIMAL
AND ABSORBABLE COSTS, IF ANY AT
ALL, AND POTENTIALLY COULD
ACHIEVE COST SAVINGS SHOULD THIS
BILL BE ENACTED, WE EXPECT A
REDUCTION IN THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE'S WORKLOAD, RESULTING IN
COST SAVINGS, SUCH AS
ELIMINATING THE DEPARTMENT'S
LITIGATION AGAINST SCHOOL
DISTRICTS THAT THEN ENACT
UNCONSTITUTIONAL FORCED OUTING
POLICIES WHICH TARGET STUDENTS
BASED ON THEIR IDENTITY.
ADDITIONALLY, COSTS ASSOCIATED
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION
ARE MINIMAL, SINCE THE
DEPARTMENT WOULD MERELY BUILD
UPON THE EXISTING SUPPORTS AND
RESOURCES FOR PARENTS OF LGBTQ
STUDENTS THAT THEY HAVE ON HAND.
FURTHERMORE, WE BELIEVE THAT
THERE ARE ISSUES IN THE FORM OF
COST AVOIDANCE. FOR EXAMPLE,
WHEN FORCED OUTING POLICIES ARE
ENACTED, WE HAVE SEEN AN
INCREASED AMOUNT OF CALLS TO THE
CRISIS HOTLINE AFTER CHINO
VALLEY UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
PASSED THEIR FORCED OUTING
POLICY, NEARLY 1500 OF THE TOTAL
CALLS RECEIVED WERE SOLELY FROM
THOSE WHO IDENTIFIED AS
RESIDENTS OF CHINO VALLEY. BY
CLARIFYING IN LAW THAT FORCED
OUTINGS ARE PROHIBITED, WE
MINIMIZE THOSE WHO EXPERIENCE
MENTAL HEALTH CRISES, FURTHER
REDUCING IMPACTS ON OUR
COUNSELING, HEALTH SERVICES,
COUNSELING SERVICES, AND MENTAL
HEALTH SYSTEMS. ADDITIONALLY Dð,
DUE LARGELY TO LACK OF
ACCEPTANCE IN THEIR IDENTITY,
SOME LGBTQ YOUTH MAKE UP A
DISPROPORTIONATE AMOUNT OF THOSE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS, AS
WELL AS THOSE IN THE FOSTER IN
THE FOSTER CARE SYSTEM.
SPECIFICALLY, RESEARCH SHOWS
THAT LGBTQ YOUTH MAKE UP ABOUT
40% OF YOUTH EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS AND 30% OF YOUTH IN
FOSTER CARE. DESPITE LGBT YOUTH
MAKING UP AROUND 10% OF THE US
POPULATION. BY PROTECTING
STUDENTS FROM BEING FORCIBLY
OUTED, WE ENSURE THAT ADDITIONAL
LGBTQ YOUTH DO NOT PREMATURELY
ENTER THE FOSTER CARE SYSTEM,
NOR TO BECOME HOMELESS, FURTHER
KEEPING OUR YOUTH SAFE AND
REDUCING CONSTRAINTS ON THE
ALREADY IMPACTED PROGRAMS AND
SYSTEMS HERE TODAY AND TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT IS THE SUPERINTENDENT
OF PUBLIC INSTRUCTION, TONY
THURMOND. AND WHEN THE TIME
COMES, I WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. BEFORE WE
MOVE ON TO BEFORE WE MOVE ON TO
THE PUBLIC TESTIMONY, I WANT TO
REITERATE THAT TESTIMONY SHOULD
FOCUS ON STATE FISCAL IMPACTS OF
THE BILL. MY UNDERSTANDING IS
THAT, THE MEASURE HAD A VERY
THOROUGH PUBLIC HEARING IN THE
SENATE EDUCATION COMMITTEE TO
DISCUSS THE POLICY MERITS OF THE
BILL. SO, TODAY WE'LL BE TALKING
ABOUT THE COST. WE WILL TAKE
TESTIMONY FROM TWO PRIMARY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. IT SOUNDS
LIKE YOU HAVE ONE, WHICH IS
FINE, EACH OF WHOM WILL HAVE TWO
MINUTES TO PRESENT THEIR
TESTIMONY, FOLLOWED BY ANY OTHER
SUPPORT WITNESSES WHO MAY COME
FORWARD TO PROVIDE THEIR NAME,
ORGANIZATION THEY REPRESENT AND
THEIR POSITIONS ON THE BILL.
ONCE WE'VE HEARD FROM ALL THE
SUPPORT WITNESSES, WE WILL TAKE
TESTIMONY FROM TWO PRIMARY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION, EACH OF
WHOM WILL HAVE TWO MINUTES TO
PRESENT THEIR TESTIMONY,
FOLLOWED BY ANY OTHER OPPOSITION
WITNESSES WHO MAY COME FORWARD
TO PROVIDE THEIR NAME,
ORGANIZATION THEY REPRESENT AND
THEIR POSITIONS ON THE BILL.
WE'RE READY TO TAKE YOUR
TESTIMONY, SUPERINTENDENT
THURMAN. WELCOME. THANK YOU,
MADAM CHAIR, AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE, I WANT TO THANK,
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WARD AND SENATOR
EGGMAN AND THE LGBT CAUCUS FOR
AUTHORING THIS BILL, WHICH I'M
PROUD TO SUPPORT. AND WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE ON AB 1955. AS YOU HEARD,
IT HAS A FRAMEWORK THAT CAN
SUPPORT STUDENTS WHO CAN FIND
THEMSELVES IN VULNERABLE
CIRCUMSTANCES. THE INTERNAL CDE
ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS RELATED TO
THIS BILL ARE NOMINAL. CDE IS
TASKED WITH PROVIDING ONLINE
SUPPORTS AND COMMUNITY RESOURCES
FOR PARENTS AND FAMILIES ON THE
AGENCY WEBSITE. CDE STAFF
CURRENTLY PROVIDES SIMILAR
INFORMATION. WE'LL BE ABLE TO DO
SO, IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
WITHOUT CREATING ANY NEW COSTS,
NO NEW FUNDING FOR POSITIONS OR
NEW HIRES IS NECESSARY. THE
NOMINAL COSTS WILL STRENGTHEN
THE ROLE OF PUBLIC SCHOOLS, TO
EDUCATE OUR STUDENTS AND TO
PROTECT THEM. AND FOR THOSE
REASONS, I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR. I VOTE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH, IS THERE ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? IF SO, WE'D
LIKE YOU TO COME FORWARD AND, TO
THE MIC, STATE YOUR NAME AND
YOUR ORGANIZATION. GOOD MORNING.
CASSIE MANCINI, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL EMPLOYEES
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT. THANK
YOU, CRAIG PULSIPHER, ON BEHALF
OF EQUALITY CALIFORNIA AND
STRONG SUPPORT. BECCA CRAMER
MATTER ON BEHALF OF ACLU
CALIFORNIA. ACTION IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING. GENESIS GONZALES, ON
BEHALF OF LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR
ELENI KOUNALAKIS IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. HI. JESSICA GARCIA OF
SAN MATEO, REPRESENTING PFLAG OF
SAN MATEO, OF SAN JOSE AND THE
PENINSULA, AND STRONG SUPPORT.
MAY I READ A LIST OF PEOPLE WHO
COULD NOT BE PRESENT TODAY,
THEIR ORGANIZATIONS AND THEIR
NAMES? YES. OKAY AND FROM SHASTA
COUNTY, DANNY GOFORTH, TAMARA
PELO OF SHASTA COUNTY, TEACHER.
MISS WESTFALL OF STOP MOMS FOR
LIBERTY, SHASTA COUNTY CATHY
DARLING ALLEN, A RETIRED SHASTA
COUNTY CLERK. COURTNEY RICE, A
PARENT, JENNIFER ARNOLD OF THE
SHASTA UNIFIED FOR PUBLIC
EDUCATION. JOSHUA BROWN, CHERYL
MCKINLEY OF THE SHASTA
DEMOCRATIC WOMEN'S CLUB, ALI
EVERS OF UP NORTH HARM
REDUCTION. CYNTHIA CYNTHIA
FRANK, JESSICA DAVIDSON, MADISON
ZIMMERMAN, ELLEN SWEENEY OF SAVE
OUR SHASTA, TAMMY COLE, SHARON
BRICE-O'HARA OF INQUIRY THAT
MATTERS, ROBYN HENKE, LINDA
RUSSELL, COLSON, R EDWARDS,
NANCY ALVORD, SANDRA TAYLOR,
SUSAN. WEISS, JANET HOUSTON,
DONALD. YOST FRANK. TREADWAY,
VICTORIA. PETERSON MARTHA
BUETOW, PAM. HUGHES DELLA
MARTIN, LISA. ALVORD LAURIE.
O'CONNELL, PATRICIA. HAMBURG
LINDA MILLER, AND JESSICA
FRENCH. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU. MY NAME IS MARILYN
DYKSTRA FROM LIVERMORE,
CALIFORNIA. I'M THE BI AND LGBTQ
AND THE MOTHER OF TWO YOUNG
ADULTS. I AM AN ADMIN VOLUNTEER
ADMIN WITH STOP A CALIFORNIA
STOP MOMS FOR LIBERTY AND I ASK
YOU TO PLEASE SUPPORT VOTE AB
1955. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. IS
THERE ANYONE ELSE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? SEEING NO
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT?
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. THE TWO
WITNESSES THAT WILL SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. WELCOME. HELLO.
THANK YOU FOR HAVING US. MY NAME
IS JESSICA WAGNER. I'VE BEEN A
PUBLIC SCHOOL TEACHER FOR 15
YEARS. I HAVE MY MASTER'S IN
EDUCATIONAL LEADERSHIP, AND I'M
AN INSTRUCTIONAL SPECIALIST.
SENATOR SCOTT WIENER, WHO IS NOT
A PARENT, IS MISLEADING THE
PUBLIC ABOUT THIS BILL. HE
DISRESPECTFULLY LABELS TEACHERS
LIKE ME AS NASTY BECAUSE WE DO
NOT WANT TO DECEIVE PARENTS IF
THEIR CHILDREN IS EXPERIENCING
DYSPHORIA, WHICH IS A TRUE
MENTAL HEALTH CRISIS. A B 1955
IS WRONG AND HARMFUL TO STUDENTS
AND TEACHERS. TEACHERS DO NOT
WANT TO COME BETWEEN THEIR
STUDENTS AND PARENTS, AND WE
CERTAINLY DO NOT WANT TO
SOCIALLY TRANSITION A CHILD
WITHOUT PARENTAL CONSENT OR
KNOWLEDGE. THIS IS WHY I EXPECT
TO LEAVE THE PROFESSION AFTER
THIS YEAR. THE ANALYSIS
RECOGNIZES THAT AB 1955 WILL BE
CHALLENGED IN THE COURTS,
BECAUSE THIS BILL IS
UNCONSTITUTIONAL, AS SEEN WITH
MIRABELLI AND TAPIA CASES.
TEACHERS DO NOT WANT TO DECEIVE
PARENTS. COPY. JUST SETTLED HER
ILLEGAL FIRING FOR REFUSING TO
LIE TO PARENTS FOR $360,000.
THERE ARE OVER 300,000 TEACHERS.
WHAT WILL IT COST THE STATE FOR
MORE TEACHER LAWSUITS SINCE
2025? SINCE 2015, CALIFORNIA HAS
INVESTED 4.8 BILLION IN FINDING
TEACHERS, GOING AS FAR AS
CREATING 25 MILLION IN GRANTS TO
CHANGE UNQUALIFIED NON TEACHING
STAFF INTO TEACHERS, $350
MILLION FOR RESIDENCY PROGRAMS.
AND THERE'S STILL 10% VACANCIES.
WHY? BECAUSE TEACHERS LIKE ME
WHO LOVE TEACHING, REFUSE TO
HURT CHILDREN BY AGREEING THAT A
CHILD CAN CHOOSE THEIR SEX AND
THAT THEIR CURRENT BODY IS A
MISTAKE THAT MUST BE FIXED. THE
ANALYSIS MISSED THE TRUE COST OF
THE BILL. A GENERATION OF
STERILIZED CHILDREN WITH HEALTHY
SEXUAL ORGANS MISSING PERPETUAL
MEDICAL PATIENTS, AND SUICIDES
BECAUSE SOCIAL TRANSITION LEADS
TO MEDICAL TRANSITION. LAST
MONTH, A US STUDY OF 90 MILLION
US ADULTS SHOWED THAT COMPLETED
SUICIDES FOR THOSE WHO
SURGICALLY TRANSITIONED WAS 12
TIMES HIGHER THAN THOSE WHO
ACCEPTED THEIR NATURAL BODIES.
PLEASE CONSIDER THE ACTUAL COSTS
OF THIS BILL'S EXPECTED LONG
TERM IMPACT AND VOTE NO ON AB
1955. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. I'M
BELLA MINER, A FORMER DEMOCRAT
AND ONE OF THE NASTY PARENTS
THAT SENATOR WIENER REFERENCED
TO. MY DAUGHTER USED TO BELIEVE
THAT SHE WAS A BOY WHEN SHE WAS
11. SHE IS NOW 20 AND LUCKILY
NEVER MEDICALIZED. AB 1955 WILL
COST THE STATES MILLIONS AND
WORSE. TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
CHILDREN WILL BE HARMED WHEN THE
SCHOOL GROOM TO MY DAUGHTER AT
THE AGE OF 11 INTO BELIEVING SHE
WAS A BOY. THERE WERE NOT MANY
PARENTS FIGHTING AGAINST THE
SCHOOLS, AND HAD IT BEEN NOW, WE
WOULD HAVE SUED THE SCHOOL FOR
THE BULLYING SHE RECEIVED
BECAUSE THE TEACHERS TREATED HER
AS A BOY. THE ANALYSIS IS SILENT
ON THE COST OF LAWSUITS BY
PARENTS OF GENDER DYSPHORIC KIDS
WHO WERE NEVER TOLD ABOUT THEIR
CHILD'S MENTAL HEALTH ISSUE
BEFORE THEY COMMITTED SUICIDE.
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL STATES THAT
87% OF ALL TRANS IDENTIFIED
STUDENTS HAVE CONSIDERED
SUICIDE. THIS THIS LEGISLATOR
SAYS IT'S 78. THE 5.8 MILLION
STUDENTS ENROLLED IN CALIFORNIA
SCHOOLS KEEPS DROPPING.
CALMATTERS REPORTED THAT SCHOOLS
WILL LOSE 40 TO 60,000 STUDENTS
ANNUALLY. INGLEWOOD IS SHUTTING
DOWN FIVE SCHOOLS. SCHOOLS ARE
BEING DEFUNDED BECAUSE OF THE
SECRET SOCIAL TRANSITION PLANS.
SECRET GSA CLUBS HELD AT LUNCH
TO AVOID DETECTION. CLASS ROOMS
COVERED IN ALL THINGS
TRANSGENDER AND NONSTOP. WHAT'S
YOUR PRONOUN GAMES? THERE ARE
MILLIONS OF PARENTS LIKE JESSICA
KOENEN, WHO WILL TAKE ADVANTAGE
OF THE NATIONAL LAW FIRMS
WILLING TO TAKE THEIR CASES PRO
BONO. SHE RECEIVED A 100,000
SETTLEMENT FOR THE SECRET
TRANSITION OF HER 11 YEAR OLD
DAUGHTER. THE SCHOOL ALSO PAID
MORE THAN 100,000 TO THE
SUSPENDED GROOMER TEACHERS,
WHILE COHEN PAID NOTHING IN
ATTORNEY FEES. IF ONE PARENT PER
SCHOOL DISTRICT SUES, THAT'S 954
LAWSUITS. AT 300,000, THAT'S A
LOT OF MONEY. SCHOOLS WILL BE
LIABLE FOR PUSHING A MENTAL
HEALTH INTERVENTION THAT OUR
EUROPEAN COUNTERPARTS HAVE
STOPPED. THE UK IS ALSO REMOVING
ANY MENTION OF TRANSGENDERISM
FROM ITS SCHOOLS, RECOGNIZING
THE SOCIAL CONTAGION VOTE NO ON
AB 1955. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. IS
THERE ANYONE ELSE THAT WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION?
TARA THORNTON, CO-FOUNDER OF
FREEDOM ANGELS, IN STRONG
OPPOSITION IN ALONG WITH LIKE AN
ENDLESS LIST OF PARENTS THAT
WOULD LIKE TO KNOW ABOUT THIS
AND NOT BE ALIENATED FROM THEIR
KIDS LIVES. THANK YOU. DENISE
AGUILAR, CO-FOUNDER OF FREEDOM
ANGELS AND STRONG OPPOSITION.
NICOLE YOUNG, PLACER COUNTY
CHAIR OF CHAPTER OF MOMS FOR
LIBERTY. I REPRESENT OVER 1200
PARENTS. I ALSO AM SPEAKING ON
BEHALF OF KIMBERLY CRABTREE,
CHRISTINA MUNOZ, DAN STERGER,
GRETCHEN STEPHENS, APRIL
HUCKABEE, AMANDA KUNTZ, CAROLINE
ALEXANDER, CHARMAINE PHILLIPS,
BRIANNA GÓMEZ, MAJOR PHILLIP
MALEMA OF THE UNITED STATES AIR
FORCE, DELANEY MALEMA, THE
CALIFORNIA POLICY CENTER, WENDY
BEALL, BETH BOURNE AND RICK
MORTENSEN. WE ARE IN STRONG
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING, MADAM CHAIR. TOM
SHEEHY, REPRESENTING PROTECTION
OF THE EDUCATIONAL RIGHTS OF
KIDS ADVOCACY HERE IN
OPPOSITION. THIS MORNING. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU. HI.
IT'S KIND OF HIGH MARGARET
RAIDER, FORMER DEMOCRAT ON
BEHALF OF WOMEN ARE REAL A
BIPARTISAN GROUP OF OVER 100 BAY
AREA WOMEN, BOTH LESBIAN AND
STRAIGHT. AND JUDY CAHILL,
MOUNTAIN VIEW REGISTERED
DEMOCRAT CHARLOTTE JOHNSON,
REGISTERED INDEPENDENT BEVERLY
TALBERT OF SAN FRANCISCO,
REGISTERED DEMOCRAT AMY ANDERSON
, REGISTERED INDEPENDENT. AUDRA
STARRETT, AMY RUSH CAROL, A
DETRANSITIONED YOUTUBER, UNITED
IN RESPECT FOR REALITY AND IN
RESOLUTE OBJECTION TO THIS
DYSTOPIAN BILL. THE BLAIR,
FORMER DEMOCRAT AND MIDDLE
SCHOOL TEACHER IN STRONG
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU, THANK YOU
, NATHAN PEARCE, ON BEHALF OF
PRIVATE AND HOME EDUCATORS OF
CALIFORNIA AND CHILD AND FAMILY
PROTECTION ASSOCIATION, IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANYONE ELSE IN OPPOSITION SEEING
NO FURTHER, MEMBERS, EITHER IN
SUPPORT OR IN OPPOSITION, WE'LL
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
FOR ANY QUESTIONS, COMMENTS?
QUESTIONS NO. GO AHEAD. QUESTION
YES. SO IN THE TESTIMONY GIVEN
BY SUPERINTENDENT THURMOND, HE
MENTIONED THE NOMINAL COSTS OF
THIS BILL. GIVEN THE
CONTROVERSIAL NATURE OF THIS AND
THE ALMOST, YOU CAN ALMOST
ASSURE THERE WILL BE NUMEROUS
LAWSUITS. WHAT ARE THOSE NOMINAL
COSTS? AND HOW DID YOU ARRIVE AT
THE FIGURE? THAT THEY ARE
NOMINAL AND NOT PHENOMENAL.
THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION. SO,
COSTS UNDER THE BILL RELATED TO
THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION
BECAUSE THERE IS A REQUIREMENT
AS THE FOURTH PROVISION WHEN I
INTRODUCE STATED THAT THERE
WOULD BE ONE TIME GENERAL FUND
COSTS OF APPROXIMATELY $54,000
TO UPDATE AND REFORMAT ONLINE
SUPPORTS AND RESOURCES,
COMMUNITY RESOURCES FOR PARENTS,
AND ONGOING COSTS OF
APPROXIMATELY $22,000 TO REVIEW
AND MAINTAIN THAT LIST. THAT
WOULD BE PROVIDED TO LOCAL
SCHOOL DISTRICTS. SO THOSE ARE
THE DEPARTMENTAL COSTS FOR
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION THAT
SUPERINTENDENT THURMOND HAD
HIGHLIGHTED FOR LITIGATION. THAT
IS SPECULATIVE. WE KNOW THAT
THERE HAS BEEN A GROWING AMOUNT
OF LITIGATION ALREADY BECAUSE OF
LOCAL DISTRICT POLICIES THAT ARE
EITHER ENACTING OR PROHIBITING,
BUT MUCH OF THAT HAS BEEN
RESOLVED, GENERALLY WITHIN THE
FAVOR OF SOME OF THE TENANTS OF
WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO ACHIEVE
HERE, BASED ON SOME OF THE COURT
ACTIVITY OVER THE LAST YEAR,
IT'S WHY WE FELT I FELT
NECESSARY TO INTRODUCE THIS BILL
THAT REALLY JUST CREATED A
STATEWIDE BASELINE FOR WHAT
WE'RE GOING TO DO OR NOT DO IN
REGARDS TO THIS ISSUE. DOES THAT
FIGURE ALSO, DOES IT FIGURE THE
AMOUNT OF MONEY THAT WE HAVE
SPENT SUING THE VARIOUS
DISTRICTS THAT WE TALKED ABOUT
AND FINDING THAT THEY DIDN'T
REALLY HAVE STANDING TO SUE THE
DISTRICTS DID NOT HAVE STANDING
TO SUE? WELL, NO, THE DISTRICTS
DIDN'T SUE. OUR ATTORNEY GENERAL
SUED. SO THERE'S COSTS ALREADY
RELATED TO THIS TYPE OF BILL. SO
DOES IT DOES THIS DOES THAT
COST? IS THAT INCLUDED IN THE
ADMINISTRATIVE OR WHATEVER THE
COST THAT YOU'RE YOU'RE
INCLUDING IN THOSE NOMINAL FEES.
SO I THINK WHAT WE'VE SEEN IS
THAT THERE WAS AMBIGUITY AS FAR
AS ANY STATUTORY GUIDANCE ON
THIS ISSUE, WHICH IS EXACTLY
WHAT AB 1955 SEEKS TO RECTIFY,
IS TO BE ABLE TO PROVIDE THAT
VERY CLEARLY IN OUR STATUTE.
WE'VE HAD LOCAL DISTRICTS, FOR
EXAMPLE, THAT HAVE ENGAGED IN
LAWSUITS, AND THIS IS COMING
RIGHT OUT OF THEIR BUDGET THAT
COULD OTHERWISE BE GOING INTO
THE CLASSROOM. CHINO VALLEY
ALONE, WERE AWARE, HAS SPENT
MORE THAN $500,000 IN DISTRICT
LEGAL EXPENSES TRYING TO DEFEND
ITSELF. OKAY. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR SOME OF YOUR
EXPLANATION. THANK YOU. SENATOR
THANK YOU, I JUST WANTED TO MAKE
CLEAR ON ON THE REPORT HERE, IT
SAYS EXISTING LAW PROVIDES THAT
IT IS THE POLICY OF THE STATE TO
AFFORD ALL PERSONS IN PUBLIC
SCHOOLS, REGARDLESS OF THEIR
DISABILITY, GENDER, GENDER
IDENTITY, GENDER EXPRESSION,
NATIONALITY, RACE OR ETHNICITY,
RELIGION, SEXUAL ORIENTATION, OR
ANY OTHER CHARACTERISTIC THAT IS
CONTAINED IN THE DEFINITION OF
HATE CRIME SET FORTH, DO YOU
BELIEVE THAT, BECAUSE OF THIS,
THAT THE COST IS NOMINAL TO SOME
DEGREE? YES. OKAY, AND I HEARD A
LOT OF THE OPPOSITION. I JUST
WANTED TO ASK YOU THIS BILL
WOULD ACTUALLY ALLOW FOR
EDUCATORS NOT TO GET INVOLVED IN
EXPOSING A CHILD OR COMING IN
BETWEEN THE CHILD AND THEIR
PARENT. CORRECT. EXACTLY THE
POINT OF THE BILL IS THAT WE
SHOULD NOT HAVE OUTSIDE ACTORS
ENGAGED ON THIS VERY PERSONAL
DECISION FOR ONE TO OAN ABOUT
TO WHOM AND WHEN THEY WANT TO
COME OUT, TEACHERS WANT TO
TEACH. THEY DON'T WANT TO BE THE
GENDER POLICE. OKAY AND THIS
BILL IN PARTICULAR WOULD REQUIRE
THAT CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION DEVELOP SOME SUPPORT
AND RESOURCES FOR THE PARENTS OF
CHILDREN THAT ARE LGBTQ. THAT'S
CORRECT. ALL RIGHT. I DO
APPRECIATE IT. I APPRECIATE THE
WORK. I JUST THINK THAT THERE'S
A LOT OF, MISINFORMATION ABOUT
THIS BILL, IT'S VERY CLEAR BASED
ON THIS REPORT. WITH THAT, I'LL
MOVE THE BILL. OKAY. WE HAVE A
MOTION, THE MOTION IS DUE. PASS
TO THE SENATE FLOOR, MADAM
CHAIR. YES, SIR. I'D LIKE TO,
INTERJECT JUST REAL QUICK AND
MAKE A SUBSTITUTE MOTION, THERE
SEEMS TO BE SOME CONSIDERABLE
CONVERSATION AROUND THE COST OF
THIS BILL AND THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE. ATTORNEY GENERAL ROB
BONTA HAS OAN. DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE HAS RAISED SOME CONCERNS
THAT THIS BILL WILL REQUIRE
MULTIPLE FULL TIME EMPLOYEES AND
THAT THE IMPACT ON THE
ENFORCEMENT DIVISION IS
UNQUANTIFIABLE, UNQUOTE, VIABLE
AND POTENTIALLY SIGNIFICANT.
THAT'S FROM THE DOJ ITSELF. SO
TO TRANSLATE THAT INTO ACTUAL
DOLLARS, THOSE COSTS COULD
EASILY REACH INTO THE LOW
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS FROM THE
GENERAL FUND, DEPENDING ON HOW
MANY LAWSUITS OCCUR. THIS
COMMITTEE'S ROLE FOR SUSPENSE IS
WHETHER THE BILL WILL COST MORE
THAN $50,000 TO THE GENERAL
FUND. THEREFORE, THE BILL BILL
CLEARLY MEETS THE CRITERIA TO BE
SENT TO SUSPENSE. FILE TO BE,
CONSIDERED LATER. I'M SURE THAT
MY COLLEAGUES HAVE NOT FORGOTTEN
THAT THE STATE IS FACING A
BUDGET DEFICIT IN THE RANGE OF
$60 BILLION. PLUS, THERE IS NO
URGENCY CLAUSE IN THE BILL, SO
THERE IS NO RUSH THAT WE NEED TO
DISPENSE WITH THIS TODAY. THERE
SHOULD BE NO NEED TO BYPASS, THE
RULES ON THIS PARTICULAR BILL.
SO I WOULD MAKE A SUBSTITUTE
MOTION THAT AB 1955 BE SENT TO
SUSPENSE. ALL RIGHT, WE HAVE A
SUBSTITUTE MOTION. AND MY
APOLOGIES TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WARD. I DIDN'T GIVE HIM AN
OPPORTUNITY TO CLOSE. SO WE'LL
HEAR IS CLOSED, AND THEN WE'LL
TAKE UP YOUR SUBSTITUTE MOTION.
JUST RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU. VERY GOOD.
SO THERE IS A SUBSTITUTE MOTION
ON THE FLOOR, THE CHAIR
RECOMMENDS A NO VOTE TO THE
SUBSTITUTE MOTION. PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. CABALLERO. NO.
CABALLERO. NO JONES. JONES. AYE.
ASHBY. BECKER BRADFORD. CIERTO.
CIERTO AYE. WAHAB. NO. WAHAB. NO
THE MOTION FAILS, WE'LL MOVE ON
TO THE MOTION IN CHIEF, WHICH IS
TO SEND IT TO THE FLOOR. PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. YES CABALLERO.
AYE. CABALLERO. AYE. JONES NO.
JONES. NO. ASHBY. BECKER
BRADFORD. CIERTO. CIERTO. NO.
WAHAB WAHAB I BELIEVE THAT ON
CALL FOR THE ABSENT MEMBERS AND
APPRECIATE YOU BEING HERE EARLY.
SO THAT WE COULD, TAKE THIS UP
QUICKLY. QUICKLY AT THE
BEGINNING, WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
ON TO, WE HAVE TWO OTHER BILLS
THAT, FOR WHICH WE HAVE MEMBERS
PRESENTING. SO WE'LL WAIT TO THE
END. WE'LL GO MOVE ON TO AB 359
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER HOLDEN.
SENATOR, ASSEMBLY MEMBER HOLDEN
HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION, SO
WE'LL GO DIRECTLY TO WITNESS
TESTIMONY. ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES PRESENT WHO WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB 359?
DID YOU PARTICULARLY TIME THAT
HE WAS WAITING OUTSIDE? GOOD
MORNING. HELLO VALERIE JOHNSON
WITH THE CAMPAIGN FOR COLLEGE
OPPORTUNITY IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL. THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. ANYONE ELSE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT, IS THERE
ANYBODY THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION? SEEING NO
OPPOSITION, THIS IS A SUSPENSE
FILE CANDIDATE. SO WITHOUT
OBJECTION, AB3 59 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE. MOVING ON TO AB 459 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MANCINI. I'M
SORRY. 456 TURN THAT ONE UPSIDE
DOWN AB 456 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MANCINI ASSEMBLY MEMBER HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION, SO WE'LL GO
DIRECTLY TO WITNESS TESTIMONY.
ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES THAT
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
? CLIFTON CLIFTON WILSON, ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF PSYCHIATRISTS AND
THE CALIFORNIA FACULTY
ASSOCIATION, BOTH IN SUPPORT,
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANYBODY ELSE IN SUPPORT? IS
THERE ANYBODY IN OPPOSITION TO
AB 456 SEEING NO OPPOSITION?
THIS BILL IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE. SO WITHOUT OBJECTION
IT WILL MOVE TO THE SUSPENSE.
MOVING ON TO AB 1891 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WEBER, ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WEBER HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION.
SO WE WILL GO DIRECTLY TO
WITNESS TESTIMONY. IS THERE
ANYONE THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB 1891?
IS THERE ANYBODY, ANYONE THAT
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO AB 1891, SEEING
NEITHER THE BILL IS A SUSPENSE
FILE CANDIDATES WITHOUT
OBJECTION. THE BILL WILL MOVE TO
THE SUSPENSE, TO SUSPENSE,
MOVING ON TO AB 2119 AGAIN,
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WEBER, WHO HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION, IS THERE.
IS THERE ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB
2119? ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO 2119?
SEEING NEITHER, THE BILL IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE. SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION IT WILL MOVE
TO SUSPENSE. MOVING ON TO AB
1965 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER BLANCO
RUBIO, ASSEMBLY MEMBER BLANCA
RUBIO HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION.
SO WE WILL GO DIRECTLY TO
WITNESS TESTIMONY. IS THERE
ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT? ANYONE WHO WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION?
THIS BILL IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE. SO WITHOUT OBJECTION,
AB 1965 WILL MOVE TO SUSPEND.
SHUT UP. MOVING ON TO AB 2044 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHEN. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION.
SO WE WILL GO DIRECTLY TO
WITNESS TESTIMONY. IS THERE
ANYONE THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB 2044?
ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION? THIS BILL IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATES. SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION. AB 2044 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. WE HAVE TWO
FINAL BILLS THAT NEED TO BE
HEARD, I'M GOING TO MOVE ON TO
AB 1842 AND BREAK UP THE LITTLE
CABAL OVER THERE. AND I
UNDERSTAND SENATOR BECKER IS
GOING TO BE PRESENTING, ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ASSEMBLY MEMBER, REYES AB
1842. MA'AM. YEAH, YEAH,
ACTUALLY, THAT'S A GOOD IDEA.
JUST TO GET IT OUT OF THE WAY.
I'VE ALREADY BEEN HARASSING
Y'ALL FOR, LIKE, DAYS. IF I
COULD, JUST A MINUTE. I'D LIKE
TO LIFT THE CALL ON, FILE ITEM
NUMBER SIX, AB 1955 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WARD, 1955. I'M HAVING A
TROUBLE WITH NUMBERS RIGHT NOW.
THE MOTION IS DO PASS TO THE
SENATE FLOOR. CHAIR VOTING AYE.
VICE CHAIR VOTING NO. ASHBY I
ASHBY I BECKER I BECKER I
BRADFORD. BRADFORD I 5 TO 2, 5
TO 2. THE BILL IS OUT GOING BACK
TO AB 1842 BYE BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER REYES WITH THE SENATOR
BECKER PRESENTING. THANK YOU FOR
DOING THIS TODAY. APPRECIATE IT.
YEAH. AND THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT ON BEHALF
OF THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER FOR THIS
BILL PROHIBITS COMMERCIAL HEALTH
INSURERS FROM IMPOSING PRIOR
AUTHORIZATION RULES THAT CREATE
BARRIERS TO ACCESSING MEDICAL
MEDICATION ASSISTED TREATMENT
MEDICATIONS SUCH AS, 40, OR, NOW
TRECWN CAN SIGNIFICANTLY IMPROVE
TREATMENT FOR MANY SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDERS BY TREATING CRAVINGS
AND WITHDRAWAL SYMPTOMS.
HOWEVER, MEDICATION ASSISTED
TREATMENT IS UNDERUSED DUE TO
PRIOR AUTHORIZATION REQUIREMENTS
, WHICH CREATE UNNECESSARY
BARRIERS OR DELAY OR INTERRUPT
ACCESS TO EFFECTIVE TREATMENT.
EIGHT AB 1842 IS AN IMPORTANT
FIRST STEP THAT WILL REDUCE
OVERDOSE RATES AND SAVE LIVES IN
SUPPORT. TO TESTIFY, WE HAVE
DOCTOR AMY MULLIN, WHO'S A
PROFESSOR OF EMERGENCY MEDICINE
DIVISION CHIEF OF ADDICTION
MEDICINE AT UC DAVIS AND ALSO
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
BRIDGE PROGRAM. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME, AS AN EMERGENCY
PHYSICIAN, I ALSO WORK WITH
CALIFORNIA BRIDGE, WHICH WORKS
WITH OVER 270 OF THE 310
EMERGENCY DEPARTMENTS IN
CALIFORNIA. WHAT THIS LOOKS LIKE
IN OUR CURRENT AEDS IS A PERSON
WILL COME INTO THE EMERGENCY
DEPARTMENT WITH AN OVERDOSE OR
WITH SUBSTANCE USE, AND WE WILL
START TREATMENT THERE IN THAT
EMERGENCY DEPARTMENT VISIT. IF
THAT PERSON HAS MEDI-CAL, THEY
WILL FREQUENTLY GET THEIR
PRESCRIPTION. THEY WILL GET IT
BEFORE THEY LEAVE. SO THEY WILL
HAVE CONTINUOUS ACCESS TO
MEDICATION THAT TREATS
WITHDRAWAL AND TREATS ADDICTION.
HOWEVER, IF THAT PATIENT HAS
COMMERCIAL INSURANCE AND THERE
IS A PRIOR AUTHORIZATION
REQUIREMENT, THEY ARE UNABLE TO
FILL THAT MEDICATION. WHEN THEY
LEAVE, THEY WILL EXPERIENCE
DELAYS. THEY WILL GO BACK TO
WITHDRAWAL AND USUALLY RETURN TO
USE. SINCE THIS IS
APPROPRIATIONS, I CAN TELL YOU
UNTREATED DRUG USE IS A HUGE
COST TO THE STATE IN TERMS OF
LOST EMPLOYMENT, LOST HOUSING,
HEALTH CARE UTILIZATION, AN
ENGAGEMENT WITH THE EMS SYSTEM,
AND UNFORTUNATELY, OFTEN THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM. THIS IS
AN IMPORTANT BILL THAT WILL HELP
PEOPLE STAY IN TREATMENT FOR
SUBSTANCE USE AND I THINK
ULTIMATELY REDUCE COST TO THE
STATE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. APPRECIATE YOUR TESTIMONY
HERE TODAY. MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS, TIM MADDEN,
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER OF THE AMERICAN COLLEGE
OF EMERGENCY PHYSICIANS IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH,
CLIFTON WILSON, ON BEHALF OF THE
CITY AND COUNTY OF SAN
FRANCISCO, THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF PSYCHIATRISTS AND
THE CALIFORNIA ACADEMY OF CHILD
AND ADOLESCENT PSYCHIATRY, ALL
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. ANYONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT? IS THERE ANYONE HERE IN
OPPOSITION? ANYONE IN OPPOSITION
SEEING NO OPPOSITION? THIS IS
ELIGIBLE FOR A Dð PASS. WE'RE
GOING TO BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR, QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. I'LL MOVE THAT. THERE
IS A MOTION, SEEING NO COMMENTS,
YOU CAN WILL ALLOW YOU TO
CONCLUDE ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLYMEMBER REYES. THANK YOU.
AS YOU HEARD FOR THE WITNESSES,
WOULD YOU BELIEVE THIS WILL SAVE
LIVES BY STOPPING THESE DELAYS?
AND WE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE? THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THE MOTION IS, Dð. PASS NO
FURTHER COMMENTS. PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL CABALLERO. AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE. JONES. AYE.
JONES. AYE. ASHBY ASHBY. AYE.
BECKER. BECKER. AYE. BRADFORD
BRADFORD. AYE. SATO. SATO. AYE.
WAHAB WAHAB. AYE. SEVEN ZERO. 7
TO 0. THE BILL IS OUT.
ALL RIGHT. NEXT. WE'RE MOVING TO
ITEM NUMBER NINE ON THE AGENDA
AB27, FIVE FIVE. BY THIS, THE
ASSEMBLYMEMBER WICKS ONE. YES
SINCE THIS IS ONE OF THE ANNUAL
CLAIMS BILLS, THE CHAIR WILL BE
PRESENTING ON BEHALF OF MISS
WICKS AND I HAVE THE GAVEL, SO
THANK YOU. SO, IN THE NOTES
RIGHT HERE, YOU DO HAVE THE
GAVEL, SIR. MADAM CHAIR, THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. IS THIS ON? OKAY.
SO GOOD MORNING, EVERYBODY. IT
IS STILL MORNING, A B 2755 IS A
BILL CARRIED BY THE CHAIR OF THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE EACH
YEAR TO PROVIDE APPROPRIATION
AUTHORITY FOR LEGAL JUDGMENTS,
SETTLEMENTS APPROVED BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. THIS
URGENCY BILL APPROPRIATES
$523,000 FROM THE GENERAL FUND
TO DOJ FOR THE PAYMENT OF THE
FOLLOWING CLAIMS AGAINST THE
STATE RIGHT TO LIFE OF CENTRAL
CALIFORNIA VERSUS BONTA, GUPTA
VERSUS BONTA, AND PROGRESSIVE
DEMOCRATS FOR SOCIAL JUSTICE
VERSUS BONTA. THESE JUDGMENTS
AND SETTLEMENTS ARE TO PAY FOR
THE PREVAILING PARTY'S
ATTORNEY'S FEES AND COSTS, AND
THEY ARE BINDING STATE
OBLIGATIONS. WE HAVE TO PAY THEM
ANY FUNDS APPROPRIATED IN EXCESS
OF THE AMOUNTS REQUIRED FOR THE
CLAIMS WILL REVERT TO THE
GENERAL FUND. WITH ME TODAY ARE
JUSTIN RUSSA AND TONY HACKEL
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE,
WHO CAN ANSWER ANY TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS ABOUT THE INDIVIDUAL
CLAIMS. AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR VOTE. THANK YOU, MADAM
CHAIR, WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF
AB 2755. GOOD MORNING, MR.
CHAIR. HONORABLE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. MY NAME IS JUSTIN
ROUSE. I'M THE DEPUTY LEDGE
DIRECTOR FOR ATTORNEY GENERAL,
ROB BONTA. I'D LIKE TO THANK
CHAIR CABALLERO FOR PRESENTING
THE BILL TODAY AND THE COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR THE DETAILED ANALYSIS.
IT'S NOT TO REPEAT THE CHAIR'S
DETAILED PRESENTATION. THIS BILL
WOULD APPROPRIATE $523,000 FROM
THE GENERAL FUND TO THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL FOR THE PAYMENTS OF
CLAIMS, SETTLEMENTS, OR
JUDGMENTS AGAINST THE STATE
ARISING FROM THE THREE SPECIFIED
ACTIONS PRESENTED BY MADAM
CHAIR, SUPERVISING DEPUTY
ATTORNEY GENERAL TONY HOCHUL IS
ONE OF OUR LEAD ATTORNEYS AND IS
AVAILABLE TO ANSWER ANY SPECIFIC
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE REGARDING
ANY OF THE THREE SETTLEMENTS.
WITH THAT, WE RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTE. ARE THERE
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT?
ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION TO AB 2755? SEEING
NONE, MADAM CHAIR, WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE OR ACTUALLY, IS
THERE ANY CONVERSATION FROM THE
MEMBERS ON THIS BILL ITEM? NO
THANK YOU. I HAVE A COUPLE OF
COMMENTS. SO, WE DO HAVE TO PAY
THESE AND, AND IT KIND OF STICKS
IN MY CRAW THAT WE DO, TWO OF
THESE CASES WERE
UNCONSTITUTIONAL FROM US PASSING
UNCONSTITUTIONAL. AND I SAY US
THE MAJORITY PARTY PASSED
UNCONSTITUTIONAL BILLS THAT WE
KNEW WERE UNCONSTITUTIONAL. ALL
THEY KNEW. AND WE WARNED THE
REPUBLICANS DID WARN AGAINST
THESE. AND NOW WE'RE PAYING OUT
ON THOSE CLAIMS. WE CONSTANTLY
ARE AFTER THE PD, FOR THEIR
CLAIMS. WE JUST HEARD A BILL
LAST YEAR. AND YET THESE ARE THE
KIND OF CLAIMS THAT KIND OF SLIP
THROUGH THAT PEOPLE DON'T
NOTICE. OUR TAXPAYERS DON'T
NOTICE IT, AND, AND THEY ADD UP,
THEY ADD UP TO A LOT. AND SO,
YOU KNOW, I WHILE WE HAVE TO
SUPPORT PAYING OUR CLAIMS, WE
SHOULDN'T BE GENERATING THESE
CLAIMS IN THE FIRST PLACE. AND
WE SHOULD BE A LOT MORE JUDICIAL
ABOUT WHEN WE'RE, WE'RE
TRAMPLING ON CONSTITUTION, THE
CONSTITUTION, AND TAKING
UNCONSTITUTIONAL ACTIONS,
KNOWING THAT THEY'RE GOING TO BE
CHALLENGED AND WE'RE GOING TO
WIND UP PAYING OUT. BUT WE KEEP
DOING IT. AND SO, I'LL PROBABLY
BE LAYING OFF THIS BILL TODAY,
JUST AS A, MY OWN LITTLE
PROTEST. BUT, I THINK WE SHOULD
BE MORE JUDICIAL IN THE, IN THE
FUTURE. OTHERWISE WE'RE GOING TO
CONTINUE TO PAY OUT RIDICULOUS
CLAIMS, FROM OUR OWN, OUR OWN
DOING, SO WITH THAT, GO AHEAD
AND TURN IT BACK OVER TO THE
CHAIR, THANK YOU, SENATOR. SO TO
SUMMARIZE, IS THE JUDICIAL
BRANCH IS SAVING THE CITIZENS OF
CALIFORNIA FROM THE LEGISLATIVE
BRANCH THAT KIND OF. OKAY, I
JUST WANTED TO SEE IF THAT'S
WHAT I IF I HEARD THAT RIGHT. WE
HAVE A MOTION ON THE BILL. IS
THERE ANY MORE DISCUSSION ON
THIS BILL, WITH THAT, WE WILL
THERE'S A MOTION TO APPROVE.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE? I THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE COMMENTS
AND THE DISCUSSION. WE COULD
SPEND ALL DAY DEBATING ABOUT.
EXACTLY. WHY THE CLAIMS
HAPPENED. AND WHAT THE
PROTECTIONS WERE THAT, THAT THE
LEGISLATURE WAS TRYING TO ENACT.
BUT THAT'S NOT THE POINT HERE.
THESE ARE THESE ARE DEBTS THAT
WE NEED TO PAY. AND SO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR, IF THE
SECRETARY CAN PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
THE SENATE FLOOR. CABALLERO.
CABALLERO, I JONES NOT VOTING.
ASHBY I ASHBY I BECKER. BRADFORD
BRADFORD I. SATO. WAHAB HOP I.
FOR TO ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES.
I WANT TO WAIT FOR A LET ME
CHECK. SO JUST GETTING WELL.
WE'LL PUT THAT BILL ON CALL. TO
SEE IF, SENATOR BECKER RETURNS.
I THINK HE HAD SOMETHING THAT
PULLED HIM OUT. SO WE'LL JUST
TAKE A VERY BRIEF RECESS. THAT
PRETTY MUCH CONCLUDES OUR AGENDA
ITEMS FOR TODAY. WE'RE JUST
GOING TO LEAVE THAT ONE BILL ON
CALL, FOR A COUPLE OF MINUTES.
WE'RE GOOD. YEAH. ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
WE'RE GOING TO, REOPEN THE ROLL
ON AB 2755 BY, ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WICKS, PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. THE MOTION IS TO PASS
TO THE SENATE FLOOR. JONES.
BECKER I BECKER I SATO FIVE ZERO
5 TO 0. THAT BILL IS OUT. SO I
KNOW YOU'RE DISAPPOINTED TO HEAR
THIS, BUT THAT CONCLUDES THE
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
FOR TODAY. SO THANK YOU FOR
JOINING US. WE ARE ADJOURNED.